okay um well welcome everyone and I'm
glad to see you here and and today we
can think about mathematics and talk
about it and really enjoy the mix in
progress and you start with with the
chocolate librivox hub is making
fantastic progress on symmetry logic and
the cs paper so thank you all for coming
organizers Neil innocent and Alexandra
asked me to give an overview talk
focusing on symmetry and algebra so
thank you very much for the invitation
and now try to be a good boy and do
exactly that so what I'm going to talk
about is fixed template finite domain
CHP so for now I am going to define it
on the next slide but for now it's just
a class of computational problems namely
decision problems in here and here's the
message I want to deliver so in this
class we know that a problem is hard if
and only if it likes symmetry in some
precise ends some more details about it
so this implication has two directions
if it like symmetry then it means it it
can express many things you can simulate
many problems and then it's hard and
somehow we have only one reason for
hardness if you give me a problem in the
class and a hard problem in the class I
give you a reduction computer can give
you a reduction it's no creativity
involved the other direction the
symmetries can can help in finding
algorithms so for example it helps in
that you can combine solutions to get
another solution ok
the second point is that if i say
symmetry most people think of I don't
know automorphisms or endomorphisms
there are useless in here okay we need
some different notions of symmetry so in
general so this is the source about CSP
and or this even a very tiny subclass
effect of it in general the same points
can be made about the way more problems
well way more problems and obvious
question is like how far of course I
want to claim that this is true these
notes are true for all computational
problems but of course is a bit too
optimistic right all right so let me
start with the definition of the problem
so this slide will reappear and i will
just dressed in the rest of the talk
i'll try to give some details for for
these points so what is the CSP you fix
finite template so template a template
is the right pronunciation template is a
relational structure which is a set and
a bunch of relations relation for me is
either a subset or or a predicate i will
use both green points and are now about
on instances it's a PP primitive
positive sometimes over the structure so
PP means you can use conjunction you can
use existential quantification but you
can use equality and that's it right so
a typical instance is here these
variables X Y Z are constrained to be in
the relation R one that's why these
clauses are called constraints TZ should
be in the relation R to YYZ ish
generation are one and we want to
satisfy all the constraints meaning we
want to find out that this formula
existentially quantified formula is true
so in this way this is a decision
problem please interrupt me if this is
not clear because this is
the topic so now I'm can formulate it in
other ways like a homomorphism problem
to fixed fixed structure queries to fix
relational database so this is really
tiny part of the whole CSP era of course
there are other variants you can allow
the no man to be infinite for example
you can fix something else so here we
are fixing the relations we can use you
can fix you call you can you need not
fix the relations you may say try to fix
how the how the instance look like some
structures you can try to study similar
problem is with different connectors say
hello for all quantifier many many
versions even in this version there are
way more questions we ask not only this
decision version we can ask well instead
of this side find the solution in this
context it is the same actually you can
count the number of solutions you can
optimize the number of satisfied
constraints so you are not satisfied
with the answer no you cannot satisfy
all the constraints in Italy but you
want to satisfy as much as possible and
and you can approximately optimize so
half of optimum at least and you of
course want to do it fast all right so
for each iteration structure we have a
computational problem and we want to
study the complexity or district
descriptive or or computational here I'm
interested in computational and only
rough one so modulus a polynomial time
reductions so this is of course in NP CS
you see you guess the evaluation and
check it so a couple of examples what
problems you can express so choosing the
template in various ways you get various
problems and so many but say various
forms of such problems too sir three sat
on sat
coloring problems negation is not
allowed oh yeah this is describing the
relational structure so I my domain 0 1
and i have here three binary relations
the first relation is just saying one of
the day it's all paris but 00 okay so
this is specifying the relations okay so
coloring problem if you if your domain
is 3 element and you have been a quality
relation then this is 3 coloring problem
solving systems of linear equations or a
finite fields or any other systems over
finite algebras but this is a good
example so here the domain is the prime
field okay and say add they're all
Turner relations which are affine
subspaces okay so in this way you can
concoct linear equations here are some
problems interesting for roller
complexities like connectivity vertices
in a directed graph or undirected graph
so there is a conjecture that this is
not so white class that there are no
intermediate problems okay everything is
in p or NP complete well and we want to
prove it and also we want to find the
boundary right how to recognize easy
problems from heart so here are some
selected results of course I'm not
listing even even some important ones my
selection so concerning the dichotomy
conjecture itself some oops some old
results on boolean domain it's true if
you have one single undirected graph
then it's true now some more modern
results there is
gaap see so three element domains are so
true for general relational structures
if it contains all internal relations
general already this is a generalization
of this graph theory result so you don't
need to be undirected but you need to
have you see only oh no no no no no any
structure but the structure must include
unary relations all-union relations so
us anything absolute well and then the
last line there is a question mark so
there is a announced solution well it's
not written up it's complicated but well
I would say at least fifty percent and
it's morally okay anyway like this is a
this is a problem which which doesn't
which certainly is not out of reach but
I get solved no nearer follow me say
fifty percent and what is the margin of
error no I can't confident that these
guys to metric from Moscow so other
results we know when we can apply some
some algorithms we can for example just
try to describe all solutions and we
know exactly when we can do it described
doesn't mean a list I will get back to
it I guess you some details we can study
when we can use some some easy algorithm
like locally locally looking like you
know this variable must be either two or
three than this forever must we do such
kind of local reasoning so this is done
as well and in all his tractable cases
above this is basically all the
algorithms we have the rest is obtained
by a combination non-trivial one or
highly non-trivial while for Dmitri
solution but but still combination of
these two principles there is a some
nice work on final complexity
classification
say what a CSP sorry L or a now and such
things i dont have space to list them so
these are the results and the problem so
now I want to explain this part so if
you can simulate many problems then you
are hard which gives you some reason for
hardness so the simulation mean here is
a simple example let's consider one
relational structure with single ternary
relation this artificial example just
illustrated reductions so and we have a
second template the same domain binary
relation to a unary relation and these
are defined in a primitive positive way
from from the old ones okay so this is
concrete example now it's very easy to
see that you can reduce CSP over this
structure be to CSP over this how is the
reduction go so here is some example
instance and just plug in the definition
you get some extra extra variable here
because you shouldn't use Z twice but
that's it right so many names for it
like I see a year gadget quite often in
here gadget reduction primitive positive
definition so in more general so I on
example I did describe this PP
definition and quite easily if a PP
defines B then C spb is easier okay and
you can slightly generalize this this
gadget in a way that here each variable
is encoded by a single variable for
example so you can use a more so if you
want to reduce say three coloring to
three shot then of course you cannot do
that so you encode one variable by two
variables say but as long as you do it
in a primitive positive way than then
you are fine so this is non technical
description of this PP interpretation
for rotation if you know what
interpretation is that's it just
restricted to primitive positive
formulas right and there is something
slightly more general on PP construct
which somehow include amo morphic
equivalents well it's not so so this is
fine print so it's not so important for
this dog for you to understand these but
a corollary we get if your structure can
simulate something hard then the CSP is
hard as well of course for examples we
shot right remarks as if you can be
construct something up like three set
you actually PP construct every finite
structure so three shot is very
expressive right so now this conjecture
about precise borderline should make
sense so if you PP construct three shot
your heart obviously if you don't then
we hope and hopefully Dimitri can prove
that the CSP S&P right very very nice a
distinction and yeah that's it on the
relational side what is so special with
this don't hit nothing special tutoring
and be complete CSP this uses this
remark should somehow explain that if
you BP constructs result will construct
everything so okay coloring
different in the complete problems maybe
some different in am the CSP board this
this tiny world there is only one reason
for homeless ok mean perhaps the comment
is that a 33 sat if he constructs
everybody animation not backwards back
to Center so it is as powerful as it can
be in terms of expensive bility as a
cupid leather any any MP competes here
speaking complete CSP ds3 our speed keep
cast a junior unit are you can a to
answer that question whether people
possess this oh and be completed
am i right
all n P and P in an p-body singers way
yes it's glossy signals and so your
results assets and PR does it yeah so
it's NP complete okay yeah that's
because of course some of course or
trouble got the getting chorus is hard
so the the mathematics behind is
universal Jibril so let me make a quick
digression to explain you what universe
algebra is ok so if you don't like
colors on this slide then let's on
purpose this is a very popular way how
things are presented of course it's
useful but for this in this context it's
it's not the right way point right so
what is a group algebraic structure with
binary relation you no relation Nuala
relation and axioms right there is some
example not so interesting permutation
group on this set of elements happens to
be set of mappings right and and the
operation is composition and so of mono
it's the same thing binary binary
operation the new Larry operation some
axioms against one i associated some
particle example its transformation moon
right now what universal algebra is do
algebra or universal algebra is any
algebraic structure right some set and
some operations so if you put it this
way then it looks like a crappie field
really and so if I meet a Model T waist
like why do so insist on operations
really you can call them by relations
anything right so I keep hearing this if
I meet some real algebra is like people
doing great or groups or modules are
already complicated and interesting why
do go like you know the buff that's that
makes no sense at all students
have you seen for irradiation operation
no way right it doesn't doesn't appear
well so that all objection because the
thing is presented this way right so
about it the right way or right way in
this context and I think it's
historically the way right so
permutation groups are objective should
capture capture symmetries right so
permutation group is the basic object it
just set of unary operations on a set
closed under whatever right and now what
is a group so people realize that many
properties of permutation groups only
depend on like abstract structure if you
forget what the concrete operations are
doing just remember how they compose
right like solvability is early example
right so for me permutation group or
group is a unary algebra either concrete
or abstract it's a algebra with unary
operations right now a function clone is
a ver generalization you allow higher
ret symmetries so the the notion is
function clone a subset of some mappings
a higher RIT possibly which is closed
under composition okay so how do you
compose maybe yeah so it's like creating
term operations okay so say if you have
binary operation in your chrome and
another binary operation you can define
ternary operation say by defining H on
XYZ is f of X G X Y F of Y X for example
like this ok so any you can build
meaningful expressions out of operation
to get an operation in this way and this
is what the clone is closed about that's
a direct generalization of groups
because there are the same as they're
closed under term operations but the
terms are somewhat simple right in
numeric keys
so this is a function alone sometimes
people call it clone I don't like it
because of this I mean you don't say you
don't say group is a permutation group
you don't say mano a transformation on
it why would you say clone you should
say I check the club right and and the
real call I would delete this thing is
that sack version of it so you forget
what the operations are doing and just
remember how do i compose turn whatever
sorry I I can say it's a set of
operations clothes under term operations
yes they're just different view point
I'm not just trying to tell you that
group is a unary structure not buy-in in
here so right and these abstract loans
are study that's what universal algebra
mostly do there are different names to
it like a variety and many other so
let's it to this isn't end of the
aggression
well back to do my point so what is
symmetry now i think is it obvious so
you have a relational structure a and
you can look at the automorphism group
or endomorphism annoyed or polymorphism
clone so what are these these are just
symmetries of hilarity these are
operations which preserve every relation
in in your template right now perhaps
there is enough time for some example
like so what is a polymorphism so let's
consider a whole and sat this ternary
relation in hornsey and the ternary
relation is like in logical way it's
like this it's a relation on 01 so if I
able to give give you explicitly the
tuples these are all triples but one
which is 110 right all triples of
boolean values not this one so just to
illustrate it is a polymorphism the
question I claim that the binary binary
hot max operation which means like
people denote it by like this right max
operation is not a polymorphism it's not
a hierarchy symmetry why is that so we
want to this relation to be closed under
under this what does it mean if if you
take two to post from the relation which
helped draw like combs okay so let's
take this one is this one is in in the
relation I take another two pole say
this one and you want to apply component
wise your operation way to apply this
maximum to the rolls you got 110 lot too
bad instance it's not the symmetry
maximum is not the symmetry on the other
hand minimum is a symmetry so let me try
to show you the argument so the only bad
bad guy here is 110 right so let's try
to fill it in so that i get a
contradiction right so what do I do so I
have okay now I've minimum so because I
get one here I must have 11 here because
I get one here i'm online because I of 0
here there must be at least 10 ah right
i cannot find you a contradiction so
minimum is a polymorphism and this is
actually a reason why her own shot is
tractable hmm alright so there is a
trivial object so I like this autumn our
vision group always contains identity
polymorphism clone always contains
projections these are the trivial guys
there are some different notations like
some people call it zero someone some
too for some reason example is like
three shot it has no symmetries not not
only unary but no symmetries of higher
priority a three shot so I gave you the
structure which encodes we thought it
doesn't have symmetries even these more
journal symmetries right now let me try
to explain you the first point there the
problem is hard if it lacks symmetry
okay
so it's all in this theorem which is
which is just categorical nonsense
basically all right so the first thing
says that a structure a PP defined
structure be if and only if you have
this inclusion of polymorphism plans
okay so PP definitions are exactly
captured by polymorphisms this is by
independent by these two guys and many
other people independently found that
this second more general notion of
simulation was PP interpretation this is
captured by clone homomorphisms and at
this point we go abstract because
homomorphism is a mapping preserving
composition right and it doesn't matter
on the actual operations so here we see
that the complexity only depends on
abstract flown and there is some weaker
version of a morphism which is still
enough to guarantee you reduction you my
defines interprets constraints well
defines means that for each relation in
B you find a primitive positive formula
defining that relation in interpretation
you can use constructions like powers
and substructures and quotients and in
PP constructions you can use homomorphic
equivalence can do so this is the saml
foundation stone of universal algebra
written in a different way this is the
bread of theorem more or less ok now for
from from this fact and the previous
slide no well yeah I didn't explain that
it's some weaker form of a morphism it
doesn't need to preserve all
compositions by just some oh I'm not
going to explain it can you think of the
PIPA constructs as a typical selects the
core of B is that is that the homework
equivalence yes yes reducible to their
page which case by passing to the chorus
and that's no no that's not not right
you must first do PP interpretation and
on but then who
morphic echelons this is way more German
construction than passing to the core oh
this is a big mistake we made passing to
a cop right away the race is just like
anything so yeah 3 sub PP interprets
every structure because you know it's
clone is trivial so it has homomorphism
everywhere so that somehow gives you a
proof for my client before okay now the
proof proofs are constructive if you
give me a and B and tell me give it give
me a new promise me that is a ppi
interpretation then a program can find
you this PP interpretation these are
these are these formulas would be huge
like double X double exponential
something about it well yeah yeah double
exponential i believe and they must be
for some reason right it's somebody
proofed i think that they might be huge
injure now what does it mean to have a
homomorphism another way of saying the
same thing is that it preserves
equations so you know homomorphism maps
mappings to mappings and it's a if
operation is associative it not be
mapped to associative operation it's
preserving equations and this other
notion I didn't explain it but in terms
of equations it means it preserves
equations well there is no nesting of
terms okay I'll show you some examples
we gave that it's always make no
creativity required
receive it until you see it on the range
yeah there is a program giving me the
reduction whenever it exists right so
now the tractability conjecture re
formulated if there is no weaker
homomorphism from the polymorphism clone
too trivial calm than TSP S&P and we
know from what I told you already that
otherwise it's NP complete right now
there are like many many many
characterization of this of this fact
here is some example so yeah here are
some examples the second item gives you
some llama a random looking equation
which is the weakest equation for fine
and RG brother actually right so a Crone
satisfies some non-trivial equation not
till he means this is x comma morphism y
so non zero means it's not satisfiable
by projections detonation so here is a
concrete example here is another
concrete example it's a like
generalization of commutativity right so
the conjecture says that if you have a
generalized commutative symmetry then
then you should be tractable very nice
right
and also this gives you concrete things
to work with so if if you have a
symmetry you can try to use it in your
voice and I'll show you some of this so
here is just two items of the the
previous slide if p is not equal to NP
then we believe or maybe demetric and
prove that CSP struck double if and only
if it has such a symmetry all right but
what we know from this just this
categorical nonsense more or less that
even though this might be wrong perhaps
but we know that the complexity is
captured by by simple equations so not
necessarily this one but it's bunch
perhaps even infinite bunch of equations
which look somewhat like this term
variable I mean function variable
function variables okay nicely station
yeah well nice description is this if we
believe the conjecture but in general
you can just say that it's even like
infinite disjunction of such conditions
though it's mom well yeah it's a good
question but but nobody's looked at it
action
so yeah to the second point this is in
this ECG just one simple slide yr
endomorphisms useless well two reasons
for each structure there is a another
structure called the call so that core
with Constance at it but there is
another structure such that they
mutually PP construct each other and the
other structure has traded endomorphism
monoi right so and the second reason is
that this homomorphism order remember
that the only only thing what matters is
whether there exists a homomorphism or
not this order itself is trivial in good
because there is always a homomorphism
between monoids trivial one right so
this is a different mouth this is not
any kind of generalization of bullet
theory well it's perpendicular to the
Moodle theory just studies more
asymmetries all right now I want to show
you somewhat how the symmetry can be
exploited and algorithms the positive
positive side so so how in algebra helps
in it so we have some tools surprisingly
the other important point that it helps
you know in identifying intermediate
cases you want to prove some conjecture
in order to look at right I'll show you
an example or at least one how
polymorphisms are used so directly I
already said that it's a way to combine
solutions or partial solutions to get
another solutions indirect it helps
improving correctness okay you want to
prove that summer algorithm works the
algorithm doesn't talk about
polymorphism but still you use them
intensively to prove correctness there
are these two algorithmic ideas I
already discussed so describing also
shin this is the direct application of
polymorphisms and checking local
consistency trying to solve it by
consistency let me go to the first one
it's old
so let's say we have an instance of CSP
say n variables now the set of solutions
can be thought of as an airy relation
right which is list all possible
solutions and it's easy to see that this
is invariant under the symmetries of the
template right so it's invariant
relation under polymorphisms now of
course it can happen that every end to
place a solution if you are given empty
instance right so you cannot list all
solutions but you can still describe the
set of solutions and a natural
description is via a generating set
right so a classic example it's say
solving systems of linear equation over
Z P ro prime field what are the
polymorphisms here if you compute this
hour these are exactly a fine
combination so Matlin's of the form f of
x 1 to x 4 is f of x1 through xn is some
of AI X i where these guys sum up to 1
and the find combinations now yep
peeling this is the problem of solving
systems of linear equations over zp over
the right field delafield of P elements
so so now the solution set is an affine
subspace it's just invariant under I
find combinations now it has a
generating say sigh set of polynomial
size I namely we know it's an plus 1 say
a square is generated by 00 01 10 right
so we have small generating sets and we
can hope to describe all solutions by
means of generating sets now so this is
solving system of linear equation now
universal algebra tells us some obvious
class of algebras we should look at and
the obvious next class is massive
algebras it also such as some different
class of algebra or cones or how do I
call it which also have this property
you know invariant sets have small
generating sets yeah so let me see well
let me try to briefly tell you about
this so mad safe I mean I'm not defining
these but let me tell you what mall
surface what Martha operation is so it's
a it's an operation which satisfies
these these identities
simple linear height one identity's all
right and in that example of linear
equations so a fine operation satisfying
this is this one alright so this but in
general if you have such a symmetry
amounts of polymorphism then you are
tractable it's not that easy the first
proof was actually really hard and yeah
this is a good question for descriptive
theorists it's not known whether this is
definable on in LF L fp+ rank I don't
think toys toy case nice trick case and
so why if you have such an operation
with like small generating sets so the
basic idea is say in your relations you
have to pull a B and okay I draw them
like this before right if you have a be
a see a BAC a sea otter hot DC so these
three two triples if I draw a picture it
looks like Z right then you apply your
mouths of operation and you get the
remaining edge in the Z so meaning if
you want to represent say a square it's
enough to include such a generating set
for example so the basic idea by us more
generating sets all right so different
classes algebras with nineveh meaty
operation you hear you know what major
eight operation on two elements at is so
this is a generalization of that concept
now Universal jebra also suggests some
class covering these two right so it
gives you a rogue how to do a somehow
try to do something general and here is
the general theorem that it can be
pushed as far as it gets so one
condition is that all invariant and our
relations have small generating sets
that's what you want if you want to hope
for this kind of approach the second one
is a different alternative
characterization that the number of an
are in very odd relation is only
exponential because in general is double
exponential
and in this case there is a algorithm
which which solves the CSP even it finds
the generating set so it's like some
people call it a generalization of
Gaussian elimination it's maybe not a
proper name right because it does really
something different in the algorithm all
right so this is the first algorithmic
idea the second one is this local
consistency so is some broad definition
of that concept if CSP can be solved by
looking locally at the instance we call
it bound it with so he is a possible
more technical definition you have two
numbers k and l and you do the scale
algorithm derive everything you can
derive on k2 pasa variables by looking
only at l variables at the time varies
question what this considering me there
are different concepts but you know for
for this general level its secrets all a
column doesn't matter really so now you
derive the strong constants constraints
now you may find a contradiction right
in that case you know that the cons the
instant has no solution in a other case
you you know nothing but for some
templates if you cannot find
contradiction or okay then you cannot
find it if you cannot find it is
solvable right so in such a case we call
it bounded with and there are like many
many many a current characterizations of
this so for for all the CSPs fix
templates ESP it is the same as define
ability in this point fix fix point
logic and now there are some old results
for example the first one if you have a
semi lattice polymorphism such as the
maximum operate a minimum operation for
concert then only very simple
consistency called our consistency is
enough right
oh yeah so it should be with 11 here I'm
sorry yeah now if you have some kind of
majority then it is with n + + 1 C bound
it with non-example linear equations you
cannot solve it locally gaussian
elimination is a global algorithm and
it's necessarily global now obvious
conjecture well obviously I but you know
the road to do it now who's not so
simple if you can simulate linear
equations you are not bombed it with
okay so otherwise you should be bounded
with right and again you know the
algebra suggest what to do next or some
intermediate cases which makes no sense
to write but but we knew like other
concrete case should make sense right
and now after this after this progress
there is a full solution and it is
really true you cannot simulate linear
equations if and only if you can solve
it locally there's some improvements
like it's never you should never look at
more than pair of variables right I
think these coops of the hierarchy even
simpler consistency called singleton our
consistency is enough and I believe I'm
not quite sure this place the problem
into n square time okay so from
polynomial to n square also some funny
coincidence with the solvability exact
solubility by convex programming right
it's the same as that the canonical semi
definite program solves it right so this
was the second principle now I have like
10 minutes right that's yes we should
talk more slowly we meet soon
yeah why not so I told you this the
simple reason just draw one picture to
use to help lemme morphisms are used
again so you have an instance your some
variables for each variable you have
sample Sybil values X ever and you do
some consistency so that possible values
are not nonsense ok so there are some
possible things this variable can Dana
now the claim is if you are consistent
enough whatever exactly it means then
you have a solution and I tell you all
right let's simplify it even more the
domain is linearly ordered right like
this and the order is this and we have a
minimum operation as a polymorphism
right so what is the solution you just
take the minimum in each we could eat
potato right because if you are
consistent enough so let's assume there
is a binary constrain constraining these
x and y pace with some set of possible
edges in here so because it's consistent
there is 0 and something because if
there is no such pair I would remove
this during the consistency similarly
there is one something I will just apply
the minimum promote reason and you get
the dermis business such as well and
that's it is very simple right and for
the majority it's also very simple and
as the dis electric all cases for the
Schafer's dichotomy theorem need all
right so beyond some particle examples
that we know well these points are valid
in I don't mean that I don't want to
make the point that in general
automorphisms are useless and by far but
it's not the only useful thing meant in
here optimization exact optimization you
want to find not only solution you want
to optimize the number of satisfied
constraints if the if the instance is
not satisfiable this is done
so one thing is these guys invented a
concept which is a generalization of
polymorphism weighted polymorphism and
what it is is actually a probability
distribution on on operations instead of
at one single memory operation now this
works even in way more general concept
when you don't necessarily have
relations but you have waited relations
so each tuple is weighted by some
Russian say or infinity now comer growth
group in an early night proved recently
that if our conjecture is true then we
get the exact dichotomy for optimization
all right so they use the somehow CSP as
a black box plus linear programming and
this solves everything fantastic and a
whole bunch of optimization problems
well I'm lying now so it's fantastic
anyway counting number of solution
against this is exact count Inc success
story we know knew that it only depends
on polymorphisms and now we have a
precise borderline borderline what it's
what is easy what is hard and our
generalization in into valued and
complex valued so robust satisfiability
that means you are not satisfied to find
a solution for satisfiable instance you
also want to find almost social to
almost satisfy the instance so if you
transmit it and it's corrupted by some
small ways right so when can you do this
more robust solutions again complexity
we knew is captured by polymorphisms we
also knew that this guy here system is
solving system of linear equations is
very bad concerning approximation this
is the result of a stud get eprice
result actually and yeah and the other
direction is also true like whenever you
cannot simulate linear equations you can
somehow robustly satisfy it
the algorithm is some semi definite
programming and some complicated roundly
infinite domains this whole slider butta
teeth because I like it very much if you
follow infinite domain you get all
computational problems up to polynomial
time reductions right well so let's
maybe not really what we want to attack
right now so you you respect to
something more finite like a left not
categorical or oligo morphic now there
are there which is still quite quite
white class still the complexity is
captured by the function clone of
polymorphisms we don't know that whether
abstract clone is enough about abstract
loan plus topologies who listen other
nice math in it but still it almost
covers all decision problems I mean all
complexity classes almost all meaning
they can find a reduction which is not
polynomial but I don't know some with NP
Oracle something like that but still
there are dar undecidable problems in
this and it's still captured by by
symmetry very easily it's fantastic so
yes when you restrict even more than
you're somehow very finite your back to
NP and there is a concrete dichotomy
conjecture where the border line is and
which our progress restrict even more
that would be finitely bounded Redux of
homogeneous structures so homogeneous
structure is fine take a redact and it
must be finitely bounded which means you
can describe it by finitely many
obstructions and then this place is it
too NP won't be an exam
when you instructions yeah problems in
temporal reasoning like cube is less
than and all relax or First Solar edicts
so it includes such classic problems
like between us this or case of problems
like all temporal reason in case it's
actually done this is not written here
this result special cases it's done all
right so now how far I mean beyond these
things where we already have some
success so its assets like a river
that's the goal right but some immediate
things we want to you to consider so
approximation it's interesting we know
there are some well almost no there are
some approximate polymorphisms which are
important but we don't have any such
nice Theory so what if unique gain
conjecture is true then we have a
dichotomy and be complete or our
polynomial by a result of rock a vendre
and the polynomial cases are captured by
something called approximate
polymorphisms but we actually don't know
the bizarre don't without this ugc and
this is a nice playground for us because
the hardness part in these problems is
hard right it's for example this PCP
theorem is its hardness of such problems
so so this is a for us like in this
fixed templates ESP decision problem
harness is very easy as use right this
one on our problem and the reduction is
for free and it is really trivial here
is a good playground for for someone
trying to understand hardness better so
there are some some good cases of hybrid
CSPs where you place restrictions on
relations but also on the shape how the
instance look like example is perfect
matching problem in graphs it's it's
such a nice ESP and it will be really
nice to have appropriate notion of
symmetric so we another examples
approximate counting hybrid car many
other variation
implant what is the point we know we
know about the batteries but see what is
to be gained here yeah so we want to
again study all HTS pcs piece where each
variable occurs only twice right so if
you if you choose one llama template
then you get perfect matching problem ok
so you have a connection with Metro is
via feathers work yeah yeah we have a
matroid yes but we don't have this
symmetric every day we don't have the
ico tamiya we don't know what the
symmetries that's somehow exploring what
really would be a better notion of
symmetry more general one right in
infinite domain there is obvious
challenge to exploit some larger classes
be great to include linear programming
into the whole theory just explain
linear programming in generic way and
our time this very simple question
nobody may be considered eyes I told you
that even for Omega categorical
structures this includes undecidable
problems and we know it only depends on
the clone to find the algebraic criteria
for I undecidability in the time there
is one right
yeah so this is my suggestion if you say
some good if you see some gadget
reduction you should try to look at
symmetries right thank
well Cindy's time for more questions
vanish you mentioned the dichotomy for
robustness how does that relate to
approximation I mean they simply because
the host on thing with your hardness of
approximation yeah so I'll start prove
that solving system of linear equations
is hard even of in almost satisfiable
expensive instances he showed more even
that it's hard to find more than one
half but we only need this part that if
it's almost of this variable it's still
hard to find almost satisfiable instance
but but for that restricted robustness
then you have a dichotomy yes that's
what you meant to be UTC mall modules
are usually marketers yeah and but yeah
it's not understood by job really I mean
a rock a vendre observed that actually
this criterion can be phrased in terms
of polymorphism but the only Connection
we have at the moment so we turn any
questions
yet one generalization what did not seem
to consider they caught them you will
not like maybe there is a trichotomy p
there are cases like quantified CSP so
you allow for all quantifier and though
it's possible the dollar is trichotomy
like P and P or P space so there are
such phenomena no we don't be like my
time we have oh yeah they say this was
rough this was body will be time
reductions of course these questions are
also interest ok I just want to say and
using my point of view that it you did a
good job